dans ce cabinet d'études et bien on
étudiait c'est un espace de liberté
un endroit où on va pouvoir vraiment
réfléchir écrire pensée méditer
conserver un petit peu son jardin secret
un lieu où on s'isole c'est une partie
privée jean louis tilly va commander ce
cabinet à l'ébéniste du roi sur le
plafond à l'italienne
on a les armoiries de gens du tic trois
gros lots d'or et ce motif du grelots va
être repris comme motif d'ornementation
partout dans cette pièce dans les
entrelacs au niveau des corniches
évidemment au plafond alors donc la
fonction un de ses boiseries c'était de
dissimuler un des des placards ou gens
du tpo est rangé ses livres les possédés
donc une collection de 36 livres ce qui
était assez considérable pour l'époque
c'est tout à fait dans la tradition
humaniste 1-2 cacher un petit peu les
éléments de travail les secrets du
propriétaire d'humaniste c'est quelqu'un
qui va s'intéresser à tous les domaines
de la connaissance c'est par là qu'il va
pouvoir atteindre la sagesse et la
liberté intellectuelle et philosophique
7 1 qui va s'adonner aux activités
physiques plaisir de la chasse jusqu'au
sport le jeu de paume par exemple est
également des activités plus guerrière
puisqu'il ya toujours l'idée alain du
chevalier qui encore présents
les humanistes d'aujourd'hui ce sont
donc les chercheurs les écrivains et les
poètes les philosophes les historiens
également les scientifiques 1 toute
personne qui va par sa curiosité
atteindre une certaine sagesse et
univers teinté hic
[Musique]